like it's almost done i can't we're so
close
okay
good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy friday friday gotta get down on
friday
we have made it through the week our
first full week back in so long
it was actually an okay for a first full
week it's always usually
the longest of all weeks but this week
was okay but i am feeling it today on
friday you want to know why this week
there was so much going on this week
like so much exciting news for us to
talk about so many tv shows like
ending starting it was just like a
jam-packed week i had my anniversary
like
it was just like busy how was your
anniversary speaking of which we
recorded a very special patreon episode
yesterday with claudia and ben about
their marriage their wedding the past
three years the past seven and a half
years
and it's really quite beautiful you guys
are being like cute um so head over to
patreon.comtoast
take a listen we're also filming a
really fun vlog today yes about that
patreon episode like we you know i
always talk about how like i hated my
wedding and i was like so miserable at
my wedding
and me and ben um after our dinner last
night we like laid in bed and watched
our wedding video and we were like
we need to stop like talking [ __ ] about
our wedding like i forget because like
i'm such a negative person like i only
think about like the bad things like
how i didn't like the way that i looked
and just like i was miserable during the
day
we don't even talk about how i literally
had such a beautiful wedding and like
i'm officially stopping talking [ __ ]
about my wedding it's not nice
okay me and ben made the decision we
were like i was shook i haven't watched
a video in so long and like i don't
remember you know i don't remember
anything i barely remember my wedding
from three years ago
but it was really a sensational
beautiful wedding and i'm gonna stop
talking [ __ ] about it it was wow that's
really big of you yeah it was just i'm
really focused on like how i looked
i know i mean it's so hard not to be but
you look so cute like stop no i had
some some regrets it was like definitely
like the la the
like a different phase of your life of
my face like and you were super young
yeah but you looked cute like stop you
know i'm officially done talking [ __ ]
about my wedding and like your dress was
so pretty and your hair is so beautiful
and
your little tiara like your makeup was
on point i don't know i need to stop
just stop i'm stopping um so it was
actually a great anniversary me and ben
had like a lovely dinner and then
you know when we got home things got
steamy because we both literally like
we're so full and writing in pain in bed
but that's just us you know
steamy steaming wow um speaking of
steamy
uh we have to address the elephant in
the room theodore for chairman is not
here
for day two i understand why he's not i
just want to call it out just in case
like i know a lot of people
i'm not even joking watch with their
dogs and their dogs get like so pumped
to see theo on the screen they also
watch with their cats
i got i got so many beautiful messages
i'm not gonna lie when the cat
community cat gate went down no it's not
a gate because
you guys the cat community is so cool
resilient
took it in stride laughing with us thank
you made me think twice about what i
said i'm not gonna lie the way they
reacted with such poise
that's the way to do it like you know is
to change hearts and minds
someone like i got so many pictures of
people's cats and they were honestly
really cute and people were like we're
laughing at today's episode like
live i love a group of people that can
laugh at themselves i mean i can laugh
at myself
the cat community has a sense of humor
so yeah um i
theo sorry back to theo he's not here
because jackie and i have a jam-packed
day full of plastic surgery after this
and theo actually did not want to get
botox today he said he's just been like
overdoing it and he wants to take a
little bit of a break
got it he has to listen to his body like
we all do he's such a blogger he's
always listening to his body yeah it's
important it's so important
so we miss him dearly but we have a
great show for you and we can't wait to
get into it
other than that there's a lot of news
there was a lot of tv on last night
a lot of tv real housewives of new york
recap and keeping up with the
kardashians we kept coming at you but i
want to quickly discuss
my journey re-watching real housewives
of new york
i by the way like you need to do it
because every time something happens
like i just like want to call you and
tell you and like you just need to do it
so you can know what i'm talking about
but i just remember things so
differently and last night i got to the
iconic breast monkey scene with kelly
ben simone i saw your instagram stories
and wow
i had totally um you just remember
things differently and that's not how i
remembered it going down it was
seemingly out of nowhere like
kelly was on the show for three minutes
before she took bethany down to the
breast monkey it was just like
she her and bethany like weren't
clicking they were supposed to like have
a meet-up where sometimes
the women do that and and they click and
it's just like kelly came in hot
no but like kelly set up the meeting to
take bethany down because she was mad
that bethany made like
albeit a hilarious joke at kelly's
expense at like this charity meeting the
night before
and she just steamrolled her way in and
[ __ ] it was
it was brilliant on both sides like
bethany held her composure someone
literally saying the craziest things and
like acting like a lunatic in front of
you like
she held her composure so so well and
kelly did what she did best and she was
being nuts and like it was just
the perfect storm of reality television
but that's not why i wanted to bring
this up
i wanted to bring this up because i've
just been thinking a lot you know about
housewives there's a lot happening and
we're going to report on it in the
housewives universe as it pertains to oh
geez
and you know when you think oh geez you
think the classic five you know one from
each franchise
but i um i'd really forgotten about jill
zaran i had
and re-watching real housewives of new
york has really been a renaissance for
me and my relationship with jill zarin
when i was in high school which is when
this season aired i
loved jill i loved her because i related
to her the most she was like she
reminded me of like a jewish aunt you
know like yeah
she was just that's me she hit home yeah
she hit home for me you know and i
wondered if it would have aged the same
and i feel so strongly about jill and i
haven't gotten to like jill versus
bethany where i know everyone sided with
bethany and i don't know if my feelings
are going to change but i wanted to
state my feelings because i feel like
housewives of new york took off so fast
and furious and i feel like a lot of it
was predicated on like jill being an
icon like she was just
everything of the sort and this show is
just it's just
unbelievable like these like most of the
show was actually filmed in the hamptons
which is crazy because they all just had
huge houses and huge social lives and
they were these socialites like yeah
it's it's so crazy and i went on this
instagram ranch just being like i think
we need to pay respect to jail siren i
think a lot of ways like
she's become kind of like the butt of
the joke in a lot of ways
um and i was like jill's always wanting
to come back on housewives and you just
forget actually what she contributed and
she contributed
a lot so i just wanted to go on my
platform and say that like i did these
like impassioned instagram stories
and all these people were responding
that they have been re-watching and they
felt the same way
and i felt like good about my content
you know and literally my phone starts
ringing and i pick up
and it's still saren and she was like
dying over my instagram stories she was
like thank you so much like she was like
gonna cry
like because i was also talking about
how like honestly everyone in the world
should find a bobby like you
like when people talk about bobby now
they're like bobby was all about jail
all about jail but you watch it it's
like it's next level husband like it is
and he's so like dapper and handsome and
they are just like goals in every sense
of the word and like if you're looking
for like couple goals
it's bobby and jill i swear and so i
just and she was like getting all
emotional and she was like i couldn't
believe she was calling me i was like
freaking out she was calling me from
boca
and it was just like a really
unbelievable moment to be me
wow that's so beautiful you're
definitely
turning me to start watching it again i
just have like so much on my plate i
don't know if i have the bandwidth for
that but i will consider it i will
consider
your offer i cleared my plate into the
garbage disposal and i just put roni on
it
and it has been such a pleasure
interesting well my plate is still full
with love island
i'm still watching a few episodes a day
it's getting better
i mean it had to have been or else i
wouldn't still be watching it i just i'm
really excited to catch up and like see
what's up with the cast
and i have to catch up on yellowstone i
feel like there's so many shows that
you're always talking about i'm like
yeah i'm going to watch that i'm going
to watch out have you ever
watched drop dead diva
yeah and i hated it and i
hated it yes we talked about this oh we
did okay yeah because like
i found the lawyer to be so annoying
i love her james so just oh
i i hated it so much time has passed
since i watched it that i was thinking
of like redoing it it was one of my
favorite shows
ever it's on netflix such a good show i
hated her that's
crazy yeah okay whatever whatever so
without further ado i guess it's time
let's just get right into it into the
past five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
okay first story big news a follow-up
from
a story earlier this week cheer star
jerry harris was arrested on
federal child pornography pornography
charge
jerry harris the star of cheer has been
arrested on a federal charge for
allegedly producing child pornography
a statement from federal officials
confirms that harris was formally
charged in chicago on thursday and
alleges the naperville man was arrested
today
for quote allegedly enticing an underage
boy to produce sexually explicit videos
and photos of himself
harris the statement alleges contacted
the underage boy
on a social media application and i was
like he applied for something that it's
an app
and repeatedly enticed him to produce
sexual explicit videos and photographs
of himself
and send them to harris according to a
criminal complaint filed in the u.s
district court in chicago
the minor victim informed harris during
their initial online encounter
that he was 13 years old oh my god the
criminal complaint against harris
alleges the boy told his mother that in
a bathroom at a cheerleading competition
harris solicited oral sex from him the
complaint also accuses harris of
admitting to fbi agents
of soliciting and receiving child
pornography on snapchat
from quote at least between 10 to 15
other individuals he knew were minors
oh my god this is really really serious
and
hearing these like detailed allegations
like puts a pit in my stomach
and i've just been reading like what
people are saying about it because i
think the general consensus is like
shock and surprise because everyone
knows jerry from the documentary and he
was kind of this
underdog and everyone was like rooting
for him and last night on twitter not
jerry was
trending people are like not jerry and i
was reading all these tweets and then
um someone tweeted something actually so
interesting about how like why that's
such a problematic way of going
about it because like it just creates
like doubt in people's minds and like
the way that people are like reporting
on it just like being so shocked and
like
saying no not jerry he was so great it's
like a really problematic way of talking
about it because like it
that sense of doubt like makes survivors
like not want to speak up because they
always feel like they're not going to be
believed
so i'm not going to be talking about
like that way anymore you know what i
can't believe it this is disgusting and
shame on him
wow i never thought of it like that but
that makes total sense
and it's it's like we don't even we
don't know these people yes we saw a
chair and it feels like we got a really
good look into their year before daytona
right but you don't know the people that
you're watching or that you're following
and
people are capable of really horrible
things no this is so
crazy i also think it's really
interesting well not interesting just
like
interesting um how social media has kind
of changed the definition of child
pornography
yeah because when i hear child
pornography my mind goes to like svu
episode
yep with it's like where it's like
produced child pornography whereas
social media has actually like kind of
blurred the lines of what is considered
child pornography and i never really
thought about it until
this particular incident yeah i mean it
hasn't like necessarily
blurred the lines but it it's a
different form of distribution
yeah that was the wrong phrase i i agree
with you because when you hear the word
child pornography
you like you're not thinking about
snapchat right and when you think of
other celebrities who have gotten
themselves
involved in things like this in what
it's the more traditional
child pornography i hate saying it's so
disgusting
i hate even talking about it can we stop
talking about it yeah this is disgusting
honestly shame on jerry
justice for the victims and that's that
on that and i will no longer be like
jerry no of course not no but that's
what people are
like shocked and so they can't believe
it they're like not jerry well you know
what yes
jerry yes jerry i'm so upset disgusting
yeah really disgusting um okay next
story stassi schroeder is addressing
faith stowers her nazi chic remark
vanderpump rules
and more on the tamron hall show this is
this is huge this is huge tamron hall is
holding sashi schroeder accountable the
forder
former banner pump rule star broke her
silence on the tamron hall show on
thursday september 17th
three months after she was fired from
the bravo series stasi said quote i
needed time
to process my feelings i needed time to
process what happened and i feel like
one of the most frustrating parts when
this all went down
was that people expect me to just
understand everything immediately and
things like that
take time and i felt like it would be
better for me to take the time to get a
greater understanding of everything and
the issues
before i opened my mouth again so i
watched a full interview did you
yes um and i thought it was just like
fascinating
i feel like i honestly want to give both
of them credit because i feel like
stassi
stasi has fans like no matter what she
does like people love her she had a huge
platform and yes she definitely lost
some followers and some fans but she has
a huge platform and in
in due time she could recover in
whatever way she wants to and like do a
podcast and
and there are a lot of ways that you can
come back and like do an interview and i
feel like she took the toughest route
possible
live television on tamron who's like a
huge advocate
for black issues and i feel like i have
to give her credit because i think that
she could have done a million other
interviews so she could have launched
her own podcast and spoken about it
there and then
moved on people do different things and
i feel like she took the road less
traveled so i have to give her credit
for that
i also have to give tamarind credit
cause i thought she did an amazing job
doing the interview like
she didn't leave one stone unturned and
she was really tough on stassi and i
think a lot of people like on twitter i
saw were like
she dragged sassy i actually don't feel
like she dragged i feel like she didn't
want to leave any stones unturned and i
don't think she wanted her audience to
be like disappointed in her for not
going at it a hundred percent but then i
also felt like she had a lot of sympathy
too
especially towards the end especially
like with her being pregnant
and i don't know i just thought i
thought tamron did a really really good
job when she either could have
like went in on her like so hard and
like left her there to you know
die or she could have been like light on
her and then gone [ __ ] on twitter for
not going hard enough
yeah so i i totally agree with you i
think that ultimately at the end of the
interview like
they reached a better place
understanding of each other
um i thought sassy did a good job
i mean at five months pregnant like to
be going through something so public
public and
and serious it can't it was live it
can't be easy and
so i agree with you she it was
definitely
the harder path to take whereas she
could have
gone back to you know her instagram and
her podcast which like
people do it's very common but i also
think that if she wants opportunities in
tv
and on tv that a tv
referendum is what's needed to get there
yeah and that's what tamron said
basically you know
a lot of people are questioning her
motives it's like all these things were
happening for you and now they're not
and people are curious if you're only
doing this and saying this because
you need a paycheck and because of the
financial implications and i actually
thought statsy had a great answer
um just about how she like wants to be a
better person for her daughter um and
when i was just reading people's
reactions on social media i feel like
when all this happened like people
turned on stassi or people stayed with
stassi and i don't know if the interview
necessarily changed any hearts and minds
i think
the people who stayed with her like
believe in her and the people who turned
on her and think she's trash i still
think she's trash you know for sure but
i think a lot of people were
disappointed with her
and had stayed just disappointed about
the situation and now can maybe give her
another chance
yeah maybe i don't know yeah i do
commend her for doing it five months
pregnant
um and i really respected cameron for
saying that too
yeah and i think cameron asked like some
she asked difficult questions but she
also asked like extremely interesting
questions about like diversity coaches
yeah where do you find a diversity coach
what's your homework no and also in
asking about
you know the financial opportunities
that she was having like she'd lost her
podcast in the show and
and this and that and i feel like she
addressed
the things that we would talk about yeah
and actually i think she went above and
beyond in addressing that like the
concerns because she even went as far to
ask
what stassi's thoughts are about jax
like jax has a really problematic past
as well
does she think jax be fired which is a
tough question to answer when you're
saucy because
you're trying to you know correct your
behave curve correct which is a phrase i
had actually never heard of but i'm
going to start using it all the time now
um and you're trying to like learn and
educate and better yourself
but you don't want to throw your friends
under the bus yeah she probably has
major opinions on on jax
yeah but she didn't throw him on the bus
which i also think like
i know everyone has an opinion on jax i
also think that's like a like a cool
thing for a friend to do is not throw
your friend under the bus and
and this interview was not about jax no
no it wasn't and she
and she could have went on a tangent and
made it about someone else but she kept
the conversation accepted full
responsibility she made no excuses
you know and i that's really all you can
ask
people to do is understand why what they
did was wrong and
and work hard to curve correct and
and and to be better like that's that's
all we can ask of people yeah i was
perfect
i i did want to know um and and she
didn't touch on if
faith and stasi have spoken at all like
that's really kind of what i'm curious
about because to me like
the greatest victim in all of this is
faith because her life like tamara said
like could have been so affected
by what kristen and stasi did and i'm
just curious um
if they've spoken if she's spoken to
christian or if she's spoken to stassi
i would actually really like to hear
from faith yeah i feel like they haven't
spoken but i don't know anything i just
am
theorizing but i feel like they will
speak at some point yeah i mean
they have to like they should yeah so
it'll be interesting to see
what happens next i mean vanderpump
rules doesn't feel like it's close to
coming back sassy had said that that
chapter is closed um that's just not you
know
i mean she was fired and that's not the
environment she wants to be in in this
chapter of her life well i'm curious if
if all of this hadn't happened
if she would have been on the show
pregnant it's just not like a pregnant
friendly show
i think that she would have and i think
that's something that she sort of
touched on is like when she said like
um that this like needed to happen to
her you know she probably would have
continued
on that path being on the show and just
being you know
who she was and this has been a wake-up
call
in all areas of her life it seems yeah
well good for her
yeah um good for tamara and truly i
thought she did a great job
and yeah this is just was just an
interesting saga to
unfold to like watch unfold yeah um next
up some more bravo news nene leakes is
leaving real housewives of atlanta quote
it wasn't an easy decision
this is crazy after months of discussion
between her team and bravo real
housewives of atlanta sarnini leaks will
not be returning to the hit
franchise the 13th season quote i have
been on an extremely extremely long
exhausting tiring emotional negotiation
she revealed to her fans via her youtube
channel on thursday
there's been a lot of emotion flying
from both sides it has been hard and
i've made the very hard and very
difficult decision
to not be a part of real housewives of
atlanta season 13. it wasn't an easy
decision for me
it was hard okay
so this is where i feel like we're at a
really big crossroads with housewives
because so many of the og's are like
starting to phase out like we lost
tamra who wasn't an og but season two we
lost vicky um
bethany is gone i feel like it's just
lisa vanderpump lisa vanderpump
i just feel like it's such an
interesting time and if nene leakes
wasn't an og
and like i've been watching the last few
seasons like i would have suggested
she'd be fired like
at some point you don't become a good
housewife when like you don't take
accountability for any of your actions
and like you just think you're better
than everyone like teresa judy syndrome
like
i made this show this is my show and
nene had that but
given the fact that she's an og it's
like so hard to let them go
um even though like when i was watching
i was just like over her behavior like i
just didn't like
her attitude with the rest of the women
yeah i agree with you i feel like it is
hard to let an og go but i don't feel
like it was hard
to let vicki gumbelson go and try also
like nene left the show
yes that's true to me like that's not an
og anymore like
i don't we don't even consider luanne in
og and she spent one season as friend of
housewife she never even left the show
jackie i've been dying on this hill for
years the fact that luann de la sapps
does not get the respect she deserves
especially now re-watching because one
season she got demoted to friend of
housewife and she made it back
and not only did she make it back she
made it back and she made it better i
feel like that's so unfair but you're
right we consider nene an
og but she left to become a star in la
yeah like i
don't consider nina g and i also at last
season didn't consider bethany in og
like bethany left too that's true that's
true like the only ogs left
are ramona teresa and kyle richards wow
that's crazy
they must be freaking out um well it
seems like it was a negotiation like
mimi could no one fire nene like right i
think she could have gone back if she
really wanted to but like for the amount
of money that
they were willing to give her if she
didn't want to come back
i mean it's just crazy i feel like this
is just an
interesting moment in like reality tv
history because housewives is such a
blockbuster franchise built on the backs
of these ogs
but eventually everything has to phase
out and change and time moves on
and it's like where do we go from here
is there any franchise left that doesn't
have an og
well oc and i think that's a real
indicator of
of where of where it went but the ogs
were bringing it down i don't know i
think the ogs are like such a nice idea
and like i really i'm someone who
like likes that having that history and
in certain instances i'm like
ramona singer needs to stay on real
housewives of new york forever and we'll
talk about it in the recap and that is a
hill that i think i'm going to die on
okay teresa judice should go yeah
because ramona has never said this is my
show which is
honestly for me as if you're an og and
you have that attitude or those words
even come out of your mouth like
that is when you're done for me yeah no
and that is teresa
tuiti kyle richards while she may act
like it
has never ever said that agreed i also
think it's not so much about being an og
but really what you contribute and even
though i didn't agree with her this
season kyle was at the center of it all
like
she was moving pieces she was playing
chess with bobby fisher there's like no
call to
for kyle to no longer be on the show
like kyle is a she's a great housewife
she's like even with this most recent
season of
atlanta like nene especially towards the
beginning of the season was on bad terms
with
everyone so it's like the show at its
core is about a group of friends
so if you're not friends with anyone
what what there's no
reason left for you to be on the show
yeah and i just think that nene like
hated all the women and i think
i think in a lot of ways like nene 100
like built the atlanta franchise like
you cannot deny it like she has been
gift memed and posted more than any
housewives in housewife's history
and she is so iconic and i feel like you
know she
claims ownership of the show in a lot of
ways and the show made a star out of
so many women and these are women that a
lot of points she doesn't get along with
so there is that resentment and that is
a huge problem
but honestly maybe this opens up a
moment for marlo hampton to like finally
be made a housewife
yeah because i feel like justice one of
these days must be served for marlo
hampton
she's the most she has been the most
entertaining person on the show for the
last
five years and she doesn't has never
held a peach before that's crazy and she
has an interesting personal life
especially this season where she was
taking on
her niece and nephew full-time custody
like there's a lot going on there let's
let's learn about it
yeah that's really crazy i don't know i
don't find this nene news like
so surprising but that's also because
she's left before that's like when
bethany left new york like
fool me once that's true for me twice
it's just
it's just a big deal like because i
think i feel like things are changing
and i hate change i think that things
are changing but i think they
they are changing for the better because
we watch some of these housewives and
we are like the biggest housewife stands
of all times but like for us it feels
like a chore right now and there's
something that needs to change
the formula is old something has to give
in order to
have like the next iteration of
housewives and i think some franchises
are getting there
yeah some are not that's true i mean now
watching old housewives i actually think
the show has changed
the structure of the show has changed so
much so
little used to happen in the show like
literally every
meal was like was like the biggest deal
whereas now it's like there's a million
lunches a million parties all in one
episode
yeah so i do think that they've shifted
the structure of the show but there is
something
definitely holding us back in a lot of
ways yeah and i don't know
necessarily what it is if it's the cast
members if it's the
fame that comes with the show that stops
you from doing certain
things on the show and thinking of
yourself in like a certain way
you know i think i don't know it's a
similar problem the bachelor franchise
has where it's almost a little bit
self-destructive because the way in
which
the show catapults people to fame not
only makes it like toxic in a lot of
ways and makes people not actually be
their true selves
it also makes people so heavily
dependent on the show financially
it's like ramona i don't think ramona
could live without the show financially
i mean i'm watching now i told you
season two i don't know if i mentioned
it
um i totally forget that ramona was a
working woman
rm fashions yeah that's what she's
always trying to say and she was saying
that to leah last night like she's like
she's self-made
yeah like she used to buy bulk
retail like over stocked items and
resell
to like wholesale distributors and she
had this little office oh my god like i
totally forgot about all that i always
think she like worked with mario at true
faith
but no they were totally separate yeah
no she eventually she starts her
housewife businesses
right but she was a businesswoman before
that also season two i just think it's
worth noting that ramona was still
working on her skincare
true renewal remember with the lime
green packaging but doesn't that one
come out
like not really because true neural is
different than ageless
but it's the same concept where mona's
like being obsessed with skincare and
like never really getting it off the
ground and that's why bethany like
bethany's at her house now in season two
like trying her product
and bethany when everyone thought she
was really harsh with ramona like a
couple seasons ago saying she didn't
have a formula it's like bethany's been
on this journey for 10 years god
released the product
yeah yeah that's annoying but also a
little more housewives related news and
we can
talk about it all together is that word
on the street is that kathy hilton is
reportedly in talks to join real
housewives of beverly hills
kathy hilton the half sister of kyle
rich of kim richards and coverage wait
they're half sisters
wait what that's what page six just said
wait what that's crazy kathy kim and
kyle
are half sisters i guess the they have
the same mom
right and then maybe they have different
dads because also kathy hilton is 10
years older than kyle
oh so a lot can happen in 10 years yeah
yeah yeah wow you learn something new
every day
you really do kathy was approached to
join the bravo show
tmz reported on thursday the 61 year old
mother of paris and nicki
was offered the role of friend meaning
she would be making regular appearances
but she would not hold a diamond
this is not the first time that kathy
hilton who has made appearances in the
past
has been considered for the show page
six reported in 2015 that she was
approached
approached to take kyle's place if she
was to quit
and i also think that was during the
time when american
kyle and kathy were like beefin yeah i
mean
kathy hilton is far too proud just to be
friend of housewife i'm sorry i actually
think even though we were having this
discussion yesterday like
bona fide celebrities like denise
richards i don't think are good for the
franchise but i don't consider kathy
hilton to be a bonafide celebrity she's
a bona fide socialite which is exactly
what the real
supposed she's very well connected to
celebrities but she herself is really
not a
liberty she really is and i think that's
why kyle is such a great housewife
because she
is that same you know figure in the
community not a celebrity
not someone that that we know but a
deeply interesting person
but i have to say like this doesn't do
anything for me
no her as a full-time cast mate would do
a lot for me for me it wouldn't because
and i have to blame kim richards who has
turned me off to watching
any sibling drama take place on real
housewives so i guess you and i just
could never go on together
okay fine i'll do it um yes i agree with
you
but i do think a cast of kathy hilton
brings us closer to this like kris
jenner moment that we were like living
for
literally my favorite episode of
housewives this season
was the children's hospital party at
kyle's house because it was so
star-studded
it was og like housewife's like uh
adrian and brandi were there but then
like literally chris jenner and kathy
hilton were there and i feel like
if we get closer to like the housewives
of beverly hills being
like actual real like true famous bridge
like i just feel like
it could be really good it could be
really good i personally believe that
kris jenner will never be a housewife
andy addressed it yeah on radio andy
like because there's so many people were
talking about it the
second that denise quit um and he said
he made it seem like there was no talks
in progress but
even though what people want it he can't
imagine her being on a show where she's
not
like the producer and has control over
everything where it's like when you're a
castmate on
housewives like production and editing
like that's all out of your hands yeah
whereas she literally edits on imovie
the episodes of keeping up with the
kardashians
right i while i think it would be
incredible if she were
i don't think that she ever will be and
so even having kathy hilton like that
will not get us one step closer
to chris maybe like more chris and jason
um
i don't know i i would accept kathy
hilton but like that's not what i'm
itching for
you know i'm honestly itching for like
another sutton's track like someone
who's really
really really rich not super well known
but has a very interesting life
yeah they've really done some hits and
misses in housewives beverly hills
history
i feel like catherine edwards like was a
good idea in theory but very poor in
execution
but her connection to oj and then like
the faye resnick like that was
definitely interesting but
she herself was not anything yeah but
that was not a housewife make like
it is interesting to have um like a
historic like backstory that
you know we can unders like we can be
like oh like you're
uh almost like a historical figure to us
but
that doesn't carry the episodes i feel
like carlton jebia was an amazing cast
because she was very very rich which
like is really the only thing that i
care about
but she had such an interesting family
very very
strange very strange and honestly i feel
like erica jane was an amazing cast
because she was the same she was very
niche famous like she was very very
well known in like the gay edm scene
which is very niche
but she herself had such an interesting
life like with her older husband and her
palace with the with the church in it
like
she was an amazing um person a cast yeah
i agree with you about carlton i really
liked her i don't think she got a fair
shake no me neither also um like and i
feel like
teddy mellencamp was a really kind of
obvious choice and not
that deep or it's like famous father
like you know like
wow that you sound like denise no no i
mean she she but she got on the show
because
of her dad of course yeah no i'm like
half kidding
yeah yeah so we'll it'll be interesting
to see what happens
it's always fun to theorize it is a very
interesting moment in a lot of
franchises i think it's a very
interesting moment in new york i think
new york
it's the most interesting moment like i
think actually beverly hills denise
could leave and they don't need to hire
anyone else okay sutton and her
ex-husband can figure out how to make
her a full-time and we're set
and i think with atlanta the same as
well i think the show is really really
good even without nene
yeah it's just like sad for the ogs but
i agree new york i think is
and and we'll see where oc takes us but
new york is at this
fascinating crossroads yeah fifth and
final story before we talk about the
fascinating crossroads that is real
housewives of new york
ashley tisdale is pregnant with her
first child i love ashley jones
she's just still is going to be a mom
like a non-problematic non-controversial
queen just like
living in her malibu house making tech
talks about high school musical like
what else can you ask from a former
disney star
no you really can't ask you can't the
high school musical star confirmed that
she's expecting her first child with
husband christopher french
the couple shared photos where tisdale
showed off her bump in a white gown
while posing next to french
who was also dressed in white he also
posted the news to his instagram page
so many pregnancies so many pregnancies
gigi indeed has really been like giving
us premium content at first she was like
so quiet and now it's like we got
full-fledged photo shoot
and she looks so good ashley tisdale
looks so cute even sassy was a lot more
far along than i like
time is just moving so fast time is
moving so fast she's five months along
which is crazy like five months just
went by like that emma roberts
morgan stewart yep everyone's pregnant
yeah malika
well not anymore but not anymore but i
have a lot of thoughts about malika oh
okay cool do you want to get right into
it what do you want to start with let's
start with kardashians because we
literally just spoke so much about house
i was like i think we need a break
okay um so honestly it was like a really
boring episode agreed
and i felt really confused because i
feel like the last time we heard from
the house
from the kardashians it was like
courtney's done and i literally saw her
more than
ever this episode courtney should become
a real housewife of beverly hills
no i don't agree first of all she thinks
filming is so toxic they literally film
way more on housewives and
they take like full-fledged trips like
24 7. yeah but i think she doesn't like
filming with her sisters
because they're like mean to her because
everyone wait till she meets a housewife
i know but like at least her sisters
have to love her and i think like
courtney and teddy could be friends
and i think that would be interesting i
mean it was definitely i would be up for
it but i don't think she would do it
like i don't think kim should do it i
don't think chloe
would be a fit but i actually think
courtney like could be and courtney's
actually like the same age as like teddy
yeah
oh that would be interesting just think
about it sit on it
that's crazy it's like between chris or
courtney right no it's you
actually and that's the way it's gonna
like the tides will turn yes
you actually also forget i feel like the
kardashians are literally 25.
no 40. i know they're real like mom
age a real housewife age it's crazy they
didn't like get
famous until you know so late in life
yeah well late
considering like you would it feels like
they got famous at 18 but it was really
like 28.
yeah like when kim was with paris like i
feel like she was 15. no no she was like
almost 30.
no yes with paris
she was probably like 22 or 23.
maybe they've just been famous now for
so long yeah no but i feel like when
they started their show
like courtney was over 25.
yeah i think she might have even been
30. how long have they been on tv
i don't know we'll have to do the math
another time um okay but back to this
episode so
i didn't really understand why literally
we got more courtney than ever and it
was like all
right so i thought we all made the
decision that she was gonna stop filming
and the pooch content was just like a
giant no for me even though at the end
like
at first i was like why is this thread
of the cuddle sanctuary like
being weaved throughout the whole
episode like it literally didn't stop
and then at the end like i kind of
understood but like it was a
really like a lot of courtney content
and like i have
absolutely no interest in learning about
the employees from push like i'm sure
they're lovely girls and i'm sure
they're amazing but like i don't need
them as cast members like at all
at all it was so annoying like
first of all that the the main story
line is push when i thought that we
hadn't parted ways with courtney we all
said our goodbyes and i made
major inner peace with that major inner
peace and it's like not only are we
getting courtney back on the show it's
like
her personal projects like push which
absolutely nobody asked for
this whole cuddling storyline was like
making me cringe honestly like because
like watch it like the thought of all
the cuddling i i literally couldn't
fathom oh wait i have two things to say
courtney looked so much like kim this
episode did you think that
no oh my god like i think maybe she's
just been like heavily influenced by
kim's style like with her hairstyle
i could not tell them apart like it was
really freaking me out wow i also think
that kim
was really busy this particular week
when they were filming because she
wasn't in the episode that much
and courtney was like forced to pick up
a little bit of the slack like kim was
just like busy saving the world but i
also think that the agreement that they
came to when courtney said she wasn't
gonna film anymore was that she want
like she would only be filming like her
personal projects which is like
the absolute yeah or when she did clean
con like that's the [ __ ] like we really
don't want to see
really don't want to see um but there
were some highlights in the episode and
honestly
um usually um i'm like over like the
ancillary like secondary
character story lines like the pranks
like no no not
that i like i like but like the malika's
the jonathan chabon
but i actually thought that the malika
storyline was fascinating i think that
she
literally was the most beautiful
pregnant woman i'd ever seen in my life
and like i actually really like
was like hurting for her like i i know
like the feeling of being so overwhelmed
is like one thing but like while you're
pregnant like dealing with all this
drama with like your ex-boyfriend
um i like actually really appreciated
the insight into it because i had some
questions
myself about like her situation and i
thought chloe threw her like literally
the most beautiful baby shower i'd ever
seen in my life the most beautiful baby
shower of all time i remember when we
saw it on instagram and i think we
reported on the show like it was like
bear themed
yeah and it was just so [ __ ] cute and
even on instagram it couldn't capture
like really how beautiful it was because
like
i saw a lot of balloons and like those
look like condoms but like with the full
picture and seeing it on kardashians
like it was
stunning and everyone wearing like a
shade of nude or brown it was just
and the ears the ears so cute who do we
think paid for it chloe paid for the
whole thing
that's so nice but i also think that the
kardashians like get
really good deals on the parties that
they do because like they work with
those vendors all the time so chloe just
used her connections and then picked up
the bill at the end
which is like what regular people do if
a friend is throwing a baby shower like
it's not at that level but
right but it's all relative um i thought
really interesting how the biermanns
were there did you catch that yes i
didn't sabrielle and kim loved it i know
that they're friends with malika so you
just love like a real house
dorothy wang was there because they're
friends from their time on um famous in
love
oh that show that show is like a little
diamond in the rough they got actually a
lot of good people
yeah and i see glenville she on it yeah
yes she was on it she was on a different
season
um ronnie magra was on it when he dated
malika yeah but that's such an
interesting like time capsule
it is really interesting um so i thought
that the the episode was like a little
boring actually
that's where she met paulie by the way
also justice for aubry o'day there's
like a lot going on with her have you
been seeing
i've seen some things i just like
whatever it is that she's doing like
maybe she's photoshopping her photos
like
the fact that her body has become
national news like i can't imagine the
pit that she has like
that's not right and no one would do
that to a man so i'm taking audrey's
side i don't care that she faces her
photos like so do i yeah i don't care
that she faces her photos and like
people just like now like out to get her
making her look as bad as possible in
photos just to prove that she's face
tuning like
justice for her yeah um but back to
kardashians it was a fun it was actually
kind of a boring episode
but i actually really enjoyed the um the
prank i just love the pranks
i think that chris jenner like just
deserves everything in the world so like
seeing
she's my actually become one of my
favorite characters on the show yeah no
but also watching chloe in the dumpster
like there were certain shots where she
like looked like chris like in their
face
yesterday they just really yeah i know
but like they did a really good job
with the makeup and like even though
there were times where i was like is
chris
acting like does she know you know it
was kind of annoying but like i didn't
even care i was like okay so it's my
scripted show now also the footage when
chris realized and like they have her
her face paused and like all the effects
i was dying laughing
i was so confused at first because i
thought that they
i forget that this is the same season
as what we've just been on a break yeah
so i was so confused i'm like didn't
chris jenner see watch the episodes
yeah live and then it john dunn me that
actually like this is
like the next week they just took a huge
break because of coronavirus
interesting i was really confused okay
yeah no i
i thought the same that i was like no
like how is she falling in the same
prank twice
like maybe it aired the week later like
i don't know yeah but i think i figured
it out
yeah towards the end but i was majorly
confused no but it's nice to have them
back i i
definitely missed kim that season looks
like it'll be good
and very real and so i'm excited
yeah um now to real housewives of new
york part two reunion
tinsley was there for the majority of it
it was still very much like dorinda
versus tinsley
tinsley just like she she's beauty and
she's grace
she really is and like i've always
really liked her but she's always been
really impossible to defend because she
can't defend herself and like
she just found i hate the phrase like
foundation but like
she really found her voice when they did
a flashback to her in sonia's garden
talking about her mug shot to carol and
ramona
i was like who is that yes and i was
like wow she really has grown up a lot
and i think that
in a lot of ways like the show was
obviously good for her celebrity but i
think it was actually
good for her confidence i think so too
yeah it was and i remember that's like
kind of the journey that she was going
on like she really when she showed up
she was like still trying to be tinsley
mortimer
from like 2007. socialite curly hair i
think also
credit where it's too carol really
helped her get out of that shell like
when she made her
cut her hair and they were like you know
she was hanging out downtown
and i think it's been really good for
her and it was nice to see her stick up
for herself like after a season of
watching her get completely shot on
yeah and i just feel like this episode
did for me
what it just like reinforced everything
that i feel like i literally cannot
stand dorinda like as a human being i
just think she's an awful person and i
guess
you don't know people from tv but like
just what i've seen i really don't like
i was getting frustrated with leah
because i feel like she's so reasonable
and such a voice of reason but her
achilles heel is that she's friends with
dorinda
and i would have loved it like seeing
her go in and like give her leah
mcsweeney one two
to dorinda because she really [ __ ]
needed it agreed ramona singer i just
feel like i'm on this bridge with her
where it's like she's insane
but i love that she is the only one who
really goes after dorinda and points out
how
unreasonable she's being but ramona
herself is like such a hypocrite that
it's hard to be on her side but she is
so iconic she's so iconic and like i
don't
there's something this season i've never
really thought so much about ramona
singer before
but especially after last night's
episode in the journey that we went on
with
ramona and leah where ramona was really
wrong about a lot of things that she did
to leah but eventually they came to this
understanding and leah even ex like
admitted you know
ramona being like a maternal figure to
her and then like turning on her really
brings up some [ __ ] for her
diminished and i don't know i just like
i really like the place that they got to
and like ramona getting up and doing the
elbow bump like i just
no but i really like i just i really
like ramona as a housewife i really do
and
i think the comparisons that like if
jorinda goes like ramona needs to go
like
i don't i don't know where they come
from no i think that ramona
first of all had like kind of a a
realization that leah is like really
like the future of the show and i know
ramona relies so heavily on the show
financially
that she's like she will do you'll have
to pry the show from her cold dead hands
and i think she knew like she had to get
with leah the thing is i actually think
ramona is like so
not like self-aware in that regard like
oh everyone loves leah i need to go be
team leah it's like everyone loves lee i
need to take her down
no no no no no i i don't think i i
didn't mean it in that way i meant like
ramona's finance like future stability
depends on the show
and i think not like everyone likes leah
i need to like leah bravo needs leah
i need lee yeah no i think she would see
bravo needs leah and it would make her
like go into aggressive mode not
self-preservation
i think that i think that that's what
happened and i think like before the
reunion she had a huge realization like
that she needs leah on her side
i don't think ramona unfortunately that
would that would make ramona like a
smart
you know self-aware person i don't think
she thinks like that i do i think that's
how she's managed to stay on the show
for so long and i also think that like
when she's speaking and even when she's
saying like when you're just like please
say sorry or like please say you would
have done it that way like
she doesn't say she doesn't mean like
she doesn't like yes she's always
apologizing which she says next week is
actually really funny she's like yeah
it's better than always denying
sure like during that like she really
deflected sorry when she says that she's
sorry and like
it might take her a while to end up at
that conclusion like with this stuff
with
leah's mental health but by the time she
realized like what she had done and she
said
i wish i brought it up straight with you
she meant that yeah of course you know
of course of course
i just think that there is a little bit
of a method to her madness like you
don't stay on the show for so long and
really stay
like the star of it for so long when
you're just like
running and chasing after every feeling
you have like there is a little bit of
strategy in it
yeah and but i think the strategy is
like i'm gonna chase after every feeling
that i have because i'll always be in
the mix
i think that sonia was literally a mute
during last night's episode
she was completely irrelevant yeah which
is so unlike her because she didn't take
any sides this season
she was just always showing up you know
drunken sailor
and she's just the lovable sonia but
like she's not germaine to the conflict
she's not germaine to the conflict
episode title um also why i loved last
night's episode is because i feel like
and now
i'm re-watching real houses in new york
from the start i don't know if i
mentioned that
but i love luanne so much and i and i
remember loving her and i love
i've always loved her even at her worst
and i feel like
the women really gave her credit last
night for how much
progress she's made and just being like
you know no matter what point you're at
in your life and like she was talking
about her dad like you can always get
better and like you can always move
forward and that's all we can expect
from people and i just like
i feel like in so many ways she's the
countess and she's annoying and whatever
but like
she really is this like resilient person
and i just stand till the day i die
sorry i said yeah and we think now like
she's resilient because she
got arrested and did her probation but
like no she's resilient because if you
watch season one
to go from where she was to where she is
now like that's the resilience
to like she has literally been on a
journey to go from
it's crazy to watch you totally forget
like she was
it like everyone in the group wanted to
be her friend she was the definitely the
most
prestigious cast to person to get cast
on the show like i think it was a big
deal when bravo got her
and she just had this fall from grace
and it kept getting worse yeah and i
feel like now she's really at the point
where she's picked herself back up and
she's
standing on her own two feet and she's
like really successful in her own
weird space and i'm really i'm impressed
by that and i love people who grow and
evolve
yeah and i also do i like i find myself
on her side when she is like
when the drama happens you know she's
very very like she's a friend of dorinda
but like she's
willing to call her out i don't think
she likes to get her hands too dirty but
i i do feel like with
and i also like the friendship between
her and lee i think the two of them are
just
like like adults yeah yeah
like people who i want to hear from
yeah the episode was it was good it was
a little exhausting to just keep going
back and forth between dorinda and
tinsley because they weren't
really getting anywhere and they were
just like talking over each other and
like people were butting in ramona was
betting and lea was betting
they were literally talking over each
other and like durian is apologizing
while since
he's talking and then like doesn't stop
talking to hear what since he's saying
it's like that's not an apology
and i completely am with trinsley on any
apology from dorinda is far too little
too late
no i'm completely with tinsley i'm so
happy for her i think that ultimately
like
the journey that she took and this is
crazy i think that she's a really good
example
like i i remember when bethany said like
this girl is setting women back
right um but i think ultimately it
didn't become about like wanting to
choose
um a man over your career like it became
about like choosing love over fame
right and by the way that is so well put
yeah and at the time
the lead up to it really seemed like she
would be choosing scott
over herself and her career in new york
and being a housewife
but i don't think that that was the
reality i think that she chose
love and a hap and like happiness over
fame and all the things that comes with
it so i feel like that's probably where
her and some of the women like couldn't
like dorinda sees it totally as like
giving yourself up for a man whereas i
think leah and maybe even ramona and
luanne feel like no no you gave up and
and ramona and luanne would never give
up the fame like
literally like i said they will not give
it up and so they can't even imagine
so to see someone do it at the top of
their game this young girl literally
give it all up for like a life and love
and a fairy tale like they can't relate
they can't imagine doing it but they
respect it they respected it and then
again so i respected them for giving
tinsley the kudos that she deserves yeah
and also she didn't she wasn't hasty
about it she
talked to bravo she talked to her
producers andy was on her side she was
on her side she went about it in the
right way
but she chose like a happiness and
i'm happy for her i agree i think in the
end like there were some really low
points for her on the show and i think
she couldn't have gotten to this moment
without those low points but for a while
i was like damn
i agreed with bethany like this girl is
setting back women like two decades yeah
but
it she was never really good at
expressing herself and i think at the
end like
it all came together in this like
beautiful way and i think that real
housewives of new york ended up being
like an amazing thing for tinsley
and tinsley added her own flair to the
show like she was definitely a good a
perfect cast like she was a former
social light like it was perfect
and i think this chapter closing it's
beautiful yeah and i actually think that
tinsley owes dorinda
a debt of gratitude because dorinda made
tinsley so likable
yes which is something that i never
thought a place we would get to because
like tinsley was just always like being
so cringy
you were like a very rare tin but most
housewives fans did not like him yeah no
i i completely understood why she was
really hard to like but
dorinda made her likable by being so
vicious to her so she should send her
flowers
so we have one more episode i don't know
what more they could talk about
literally like
i think they're going to go back in on
ramona and dorinda
i mean jordan it's just exhaust like i
would love to for everyone to go in on
duranda but it's absolutely exhausting
to like
watch her argue with women because first
of all she's just all over the place she
deflects to flex and she never actually
gets held accountable again she never
actually apologizes
so it's like fruitless it's fruitless
you know if she could like have a
come to jesus moment and be like yeah i
saw myself this season
that's not who i want to be i think
we're also look at tinsley we're all
capable look at the way that we
appreciate tinsley we are all capable of
changing our opinions of course
about people based on on their growth
but when
when you're doubling down right i feel
like the housewives community is
actually very
forgiving in the sense like someone can
act like an animal but if they own it
like completely
i think it actually makes people mix
fans respect the housewife more
but the worst thing you can do is double
down on really poor behavior and like
not give a [ __ ] and not apologize
because then it's like you're
you're disposable in the franchise like
no one wants to watch that yeah or
like you can double down here and there
like if you really believe
something but like to not apologize at
all like everyone
even our favorite housewives like they
probably have one thing to apologize for
yeah
but to not be able to see yourself in
the wrong ever yeah is a really bad
quality as a human being and a housewife
yep and that's what ramona said last
night to during issues like your
achilles heel is that you can never be
long and it is going to be your
detriment and i actually think that that
is why
she got fired that's actually very well
put yeah ramana ramona i mean ramona
says things like that and then she
doesn't know how to pronounce kudos
is it tsunami tsunami is it tsunami
she's she's so funny like but that's why
she's a legend literally her getting up
and going to the bathroom and forgetting
her man and she's
paused it's like i feel like we've all
been there
it was so real it was so but then also
when it was a lunch break all the women
got up
and everyone was yelling at her to get
her mask like everyone forgot their mess
like by the way that's life it's like
you go to a restaurant and like you
don't have to wear your mask at a
restaurant then you get to go to the
bathroom literally you pause as you're
walking because you realize you forgot
your mask
yeah it was so funny and her clear mask
has just become like this iconic
thing for her she should come out with
merch honestly that would be really
funny
oh my god so it was a good episode it
was fine um wraps up next week and then
our docket gets kind of cleared because
we're done with beverly hills in new
york but then salt lake city starts
in november which is kind of far salt
lake city is going to make me really
want to go to utah like
i can already i can already feel it in
my bones and then don't be tardy so we
have
it's an exciting time to be a bravo fan
yep it is and it's exciting time to be a
jew because it's rosh hashanah tonight
right so to all our jewish followers we
hope you have a sweet happy and healthy
um enjoy time with your family put your
phone down
if you're not jewish feel free to use
this as a renaissance anyway because i'm
done with this year so i'm starting new
year yeah on monday it's new year new me
everyone's like when 2020 is over but
it's like it's over first
is over the shana is over you know you
can start again like you could start
your new year
tomorrow if you want to unfortunately
like rosh hashanah means we're one step
closer to yom kippur which
it actually means we are 10 days away
we're gonna start the countdown here
with the toast
by the way i didn't even think about can
you imagine yummy poor breath in a mask
no i know and some people were saying
like at least you won't have to smell
other people's breath
because of the mask i'm like i'm not
concerned with other people's well i am
but i'm more concerned
with my own and my own in a mask is
going to be
toxic deadly deadly so when you're at
temple
if you're going to temple this year pray
for us in our breath okay yes
and if you're not doing anything have a
amazing weekend don't drink and drive
have a good time
and we'll see you on monday i hope you
guys enjoyed today's episode thank you
so much for listening to the morning
toast the millennial morning show where
we deliver the past five stories that
you need to know before we wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
every weekday monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching us on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
we are also available as a podcast and
where podcast can be found and now we're
newly available on amazon music they now
have podcasts so you can listen to us
there you can also listen to us on
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
already cast blocks
all the places wherever you listen to
podcast find us the morning toast and
leave a five star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are
we love you guys so much thank you for
an amazing week and we will see you on
monday
goodbye
you